monsieur je voulais vous aussi vous vous
interrogez comme ça on fait une enquête
sur les la lecture est ce que vous aimez
lire vous lisez pas bien mais moi le
soir qu'on avait soupé je vais me
coucher
[Musique]
un éleveur d'armes nous avait dit près
du mas thibert ankama je crois que vous
rencontrerez un berger qui lit beaucoup
au coucher du soleil rentrant ses
moutons voici maurice c'est pourquoi
vous avez choisi père j'ai plutôt peur
aux métiers parce que c'est un métier un
vrai et vous pensez que vous trouvez
plus le temps de lire ici en gardant les
moutons ou en rentrant chez eux le soir
c'est vous qui en étant fonctionnaire
ouvriers d'huîtres est là c'est tout le
contexte toujours gourmand monsieur
parce que fonctionnaire pour moi je
jouerai été diminués quoi sinon tous les
domaines physiquement intellectuellement
quoi j'aurais été limités j'aurais pas
été libres de toute façon ça peut pas
contrôler que j'écarte des cadres
qu'est-ce que vous avez aimé lire ton
gosse get on go par les caisses des
prêts à 18h la commencé à lire pour moi
qu'est ce qui a eu comme oeuvre
marquante à ce pont il ya eu un beau et
puis puis la suite c'est à dire des
poètes quoi
et poète * essentiellement à partir de
18 ans même c'est ça qui compte
c'est une révélation et puis je suis
limité alors oui vraiment vraiment trop
même si critiquable bon sens vraiment je
le disais plus que sa femme qui sied
comme autre poète après vous eh ben ah
ben il fallait que je voie elle alors
j'ai pris tout ce communiqué mais aussi
beaucoup qui m'est indiqué par le nez
quoi et j'avais découvert beaucoup de
moi même sommes pratiquement pas pas
guider et puis je suis arrivé à charge
tout simplement fille j'y suis resté
parce que ton va pas plus loin que j'ai
toutes ces oeuvres pratiquement et puis
j'ai plus j'y vais à fond parce que
parce que c'est essentiel
est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
rentrer dans le charme d'emblée il faut
avoir un nom alors non non tu pouvais
rester il faut être un peu
enfin il faut vraiment avoir plus que
salir quoi vous avez n'ont qu'une
passion pour rené char est ce que ce
n'est pas un poète qui est assez comment
dire ce qu'ils passaient de manière
péjorative enfin peu intellectuel on
imaginerait que dans la nature comme ça
vous aimiez les poètes plus plus
lyriques ou plus sensible sur le rhin et
non parce que tout se passe là et nature
à avoir bien sûr parce que ça fait quand
même de l'ouverture mais en fait il
s'agit d'amener de l'ouverture ici comme
ça on aura gagné d'écoliers et parce que
la couverture
je suis combien la pavane omar sy peine
alors là je vois que vous avez beaucoup
s'adapter celui là vous l'avez lu
partout nous envoient partout à l'oeuvre
à halle en oeuvre dans tous les lieux
aussi et on a fêté ça que les muses et
un peu partout quoi avant de réciter
deux de passage qu'il trouve l1 c'est
l'icône et ce soit au dessus d'un point
qui s'appelle jacquemart et julien je
t'aime grave je t'aime mes mains ne
serait pas s'accrocher sans toi la vigne
image bien simple et vrai de ma présence
dans la terre et un autre qui sous un
problème s'appelle traverse pourrait
rappeler la colline qui l'a bien servi
descente au rang dans son dos les
langues pauvres de salut les mulets
auprès du fonds fait la face rose de
l'ornière tourner deux fois vers l'huile
ondes de son miroir la méchanceté d'or
il est tel qu'il se réveille et en
dessous vous avez écrit ici la force
devient fait ici tu deviens grands
étaient yeux n'ont jamais rêvé
cela se voit si bien des doublés à
l'intérieur d'un chemin
larose détendue du soleil il ya encore
beaucoup de verre comme cela et j'espère
qu'un jour vous les réunir et pour nous
vous ne serez pas les rats les manger
comme avait dit tout à l'heure
elle profite vraiment beau dans une
quête le mistral s'élever à l'abri d'une
meule de paille nous bavardons avec
andré lemaître berger
alors vous êtes m bergé sur ces domaines
car ça fait l'auteur changer de la
personne et vous avez été vue de
commencer le berger un village vient
vous dire je donne de bach dang van
damme
elle est de dix ans je n'aurai pas
beaucoup pour sur les 511 belle vie à
1914 par les aînés sont partis dans les
douves et j'ai eu des vergers 500 % pour
le mental ne parvenait déjà deux gîtes
sur le soir mon père revenait d'un
compte tenir compagnie on n'est pas bien
on trouve un joueur joue au mental et
l'inde vont alors vous connaissez pour
l'école label les chercher chez leslie
alors mois d'octobre voire je reprenais
l'école et puis on m'a donné les paroles
nous retirer de l'école m prikhodko
est-ce que vous avez eue dans votre vie
de berger le temps de lire peu oui
beaucoup
oui oui y'a des campanules était beau et
dans le temps de lire tout quoi le
plombier de boucaines nous parle du
concours quoi tout intéressant dans le
cross et qu'est-ce que vous avez aimé
particulièrement dans vos lectures au
bout je me dis à l'aller les voilà vous
savez la réalité ou chalets la vie dans
le monde alors comme je les ai souvent
castration voit les gens comme ça
la cmp avait ainsi comme le même livre 6
à peu près le même élection
panique chez un chat voilà ça s'appelle
des lions au favori là où dans la
montagne c'est le calme et la
tranquillité ma loge avait ce local
laroche avait dit quoi vous avez parmi
vous berger un berger qui lit beaucoup
là vous savez il doit avoir un oiseau m
est ce que vous en pensez parce que vous
savez un jour il ya un éleveur qui est
d'une qui m'a dit comme ça à 6 un verger
qui lie alors c'est pas un bon berger
parce qu'il survive à son troupeau à
bien sa vie rocard oria ya celui qui
alors qu'il y trop trop fort et qui ne
s'occupent plus là celui qui a la chance
entre aurélie et puis je regarde et se
relayent au centre ou à remettre ma faim
dans la montagne un jeune éleveur berger
serge propriétaire d'un troupeau de 250
têtes berger depuis longtemps ça fait
environ 16 ans six heures et vous avez
fait l'école de bergers les comores en
gruyère est-ce que vous avez
suffisamment de loisirs pour lire encore
oui le soir l'hiver le soir l'été dans
la journée parce que la bête mais la
chaleur ne venge pas ce qui me laisse
quand même quatre ou cinq choeurs ou si
le produit en même le soir et alors
qu'ils sont quels sont aujourd'hui vos
lectures bienfaits de lecture
périodiques en période j'ai lu sartre en
l'adolescence journaux qui correspondait
à une époque aussi à quel âge environ 17
ans un tour je me suis détaché de ses
auteurs ont marqué pour lire je n'ai
aucune lecture particulière je porte
quel bouquin s'il vient des san antonio
que mais est ce que l'homme la passion
pour sartre à une époque correspond à
une triche chez vous et non pas du tout
c'est un disons à hazard je suis tombé
sur le bouquin de ça j'avais entendu
parler de lui ils avaient des opinions
qui correspondait au miel sur ce un tas
de planches selon militaire sur le plan
de la poupée blonde enfin quantité
ondines espoirs et les théories de
sartre en les résumant n'est ce pas
qu'on doit faire sa vie et que
mais libre de se créer son destin est ce
que ce que ça vous préoccupe ce problème
est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
votre vie en choisissant ce métier je
pense oui enfin je crois avoir trouvé
une idée cc c'est vrai dans l'eau n'est
que ça réunit des loisirs en même temps
est énorme élan de liberté
ce que vous considérez un peu mieux vaut
privilégier avec semaine aux côtés
astruit un peu est-ce que lorsque vous
êtes dans les champs comme ça tout seul
avec vos moutons ce qui vous arrive de
méditer regarder les étoiles et vous
interroger sur les espaces infinis
[Musique]
regarder les étoiles en sans fatigue
elles sont tout de même scintillement
fond y'a rien à voir une arrivera en
manque d'être le soir à regarder ses
toiles est ce que le soir je suis chez
moi je préfère regarder le feu de
cheminée qui n'a rien de plus je ne lis
jamais dans l'est quand je suis dans la
montagne
alors on observe je m'intéressais aux
fourmis
j'ai lu de livre sur les fonds mis sur
les abeilles sont enfin tout ce qui peut
se trouver en sol pour recel
qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est ce qui
vous a particulièrement élevé du lait
mais terlain oui oui oui c'est même un
terrain derrière celle du met
c'est vraiment extraordinaire c'est
cette cécité est vraiment des
civilisations un grand c est organisée
l'évidence vous fait pas peur cette
civilisation
oh je suis dans deux ans je vis en deux
ans la civilisation de la politique je
m'intéresse que de loi
c'est grâce aux libraires de
saint-rémy-de-provence que nous avons
fait la connaissance d'un de ses clients
jean noé le berger vous avez le temps de
dire quand vous regardez les moutons
pour ça c'est pas la taille qui nous
marque lire et méditer surtout méditer
c'est parce que la lecture en elle même
ses parasols
c'est un point surtout c'est un point de
départ
mais c'est surtout la simulation comme
un fait qui compte alors au fond
l'important ce n'est pas de lire un
livre tous les jours mais c'est de
réfléchir sur l'i phone à lui surtout ce
n'est pas la quantité qui compte ni même
parfois peut-être la qualité mais c'est
surtout l'usagé qu'on en fait le profit
la maturation
puis ce qui ressort après et vous avez
comme sujet d'intérêt qu'est ce que
c'est tout ce qui peut me donner quelque
chose à penser à me mettre sur la voie
vous intéresser la philosophie oui oui
sarah si vous préférez zarathoustra dit
sur la méthode ou du confrère peut-être
un discours la méthode c'est pas parce
que je suis français je suis peut être
plus précis discours la méthode c'est
plutôt sais plus voici sa part le zéro
sa part de zéro s abattit tour et
sabbatique et vous avez vous aimé la
sagesse de montaigne qui est un peu
sceptique comme ça pas tout à fait pas
tout à fait pas tout à fait je préfère
franchement le doute de d'escarpins
aller alors nous parlions les
philosophes mais vous dites vous avez eu
un penchant naturel avait tracé un
philosophie vous avez l'occasion de
faire des études avant d'être berger
j'ai fait l'école communale j'étais
surtout doué pour les mathématiques à ça
c'est pas du tout la même chose
la philosophie et les sciences un genre
de sujet tu es ma table vous avez perdu
la foi en route ou pas et c'est à dire
que au début j'avais un doute à ce
n'était pas la fois que je savais que
j'avais c'était le doute et c'est de
cette doute que je voulais faire une
certitude positives ou négatives
et vous l'avez sûr c'est dans les livres
et je vais chercher dans les livres way
et aime plus par la médication parce que
les livres
disons que j'ai horreur du d'une vérité
tout fait comme nous donne il faut
commander ce quartier il faut là là
qu'on saura par soi même
et vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui on peut
avoir une conception du monde on peut
comprendre le monde dans lequel on dit
c'est toujours très difficile
je dirais même que c'est de plus en plus
difficile il n'y a que les personnes qui
vont main dans un idéal une fois que
cela ils peuvent avoir une conception
net de leur univers mais celui qui veut
vraiment trouver
il reste un peu dans l'incertitude d'un
flottement parce que si vraiment il y
avait quelque chose vraiment certes et
il est évident qu'avec tous les penseurs
qu'il y avait les moyens que l'on a de
faire connaître la pensée
il est évident que ce soit éliminés
s'ils avaient quelque chose de certitude
absolue
si quelqu'un l'avait alors que l'avion
ne serait là il n'y a pas de certitude
est ce que vous prenez des notes sur ce
que ses pensées cette méditation vous
avez dans vos champs oui oui au gré de
l'inspiration
je marque
et ce sont des pensées comme ça sur la
vie et sur la wii des pensées
philosophiques ou départ cd v rik et que
je me fais à moi même
alors là ce sont des notes que vous
prenez dans les champs vous aurez du
papier dans un échange gros j'ai
toujours quelque chose pour les filles
ce qui me poussera mais j'aimerais bien
que vous nous disiez dieu est le
commencement
pourquoi ce qu'il manifestait n'at-il
pas inconscient n'est-il pas victime de
son automatisme
n'est-il pas lui-même un mot esclave est
il aussi omniscient comme vient de le
faire croire oui pourquoi s'est il
manifesté
il n'avait aucunement besoin sachez
simplement pour le plaisir égoïste de
faire quelque chose de se dégourdir un
peu les jambes ou de voir ce qu'il était
capable de faire
ou plutôt pour ce miroiter dans sa
création comme nous le sapin c'est le
philosophe béatement et luis train
c'est le cas de le dire le nivernais
personnel ce qui serait d'ailleurs le
pur narcissisme
semir wade dans sa création de mars
c'est une belle image et ses livres
lorsque vous les lisez vous ne conservez
pas remet pas du biotech ici non non
principe non je les conserve un certain
temps puis 15 g stream qui sort superflu
périmés ou je réponds à quelqu'un je
veux me laisser n'importe comment
vous n'avez pas du tout envie de
posséder des objets non et je ne
m'attache pas trop quand ça aussi c'est
la sagesse à ça c'est pas moi c'est une
forme du relancement pour changer de
sujet parce qu'on est dans les sujets
croit on va chercher là un livre je vois
vous avez là le commissaire san antonio
c'est un roman policier danois a asséné
futilités l'on vous parliez on est choyé
aïe ça c'est pour ces pour tout oublier
c'est une récréation ça c'est un lavage
de cervelle et temps en temps ça faisait
ça vous distrait ça vous amuse alors que
vous en vivez un c pour parce que c'est
vraiment si on veut vraiment ça c'est de
l'étude
c'est pour les idéaux du travail alors
que ça ce n'est pas ce talent alors vous
la lecture c'est tout c'est à la fois la
distraction la culture la méditation
vous trouvez toutes les chutes ou et
semaine je fais je fais deux par une
part entre le pasteur agréable et
d'autre part entre la méditation et
tuent dans le sens profond des choses
son temps de chien qui vous réclame là
on va à évin lors sa patte et arts
d'oran fait alors vous avons donné
[Musique]